ah il en a accompagné un des jeunes
femmes et des moins jeunes d'ailleurs ce
film comme t'y es belle lisa azuelos en
2006 incroyable incroyable parce que
mais en tout cas c'est quand je revois
cet extrait c'est marrant je quand je le
vois je vois pas tant l'image où je
m'aime pas - et toujours je ressens
comme j'avais peur comme j'ai eu peur
tous les jours en faisant l'actrice sur
ce film parce que précisément je n'étais
pas actrice que c'était un truc qui
arrivé un peu par hasard comme ça je
travaillais justement la production sur
la chaîne comédie on m'appelle sur mon
téléphone fixe parce que je m'occupe
aussi du casting de la chaîne puisque
occupé entre autres des cafés et du
casting c'est comme ça la comédie et on
me demandait ce que tu veux venir pour
le casting d'un film qui s'appelle comme
t'y es belle et puis je dis pas non mais
moi je suis déjà en cdi donc je peux pas
faire le casting on dit non merci pour
le passé le casting donc j'ai vaches et
non parce que justement je suis en cdi
je raccroche puis je rappelle parce que
je me dis bien mais quand même bien
j'aime bien l'idée cette photo et
[Musique]
oui avec michèle laroque qui valérie
béni nous a quittés
c'est là encore il ya vachement cette
notion de sororité elles sont il ya aura
ti-cats aussi bien sûr dans ce dans ce
film tout cela ce chapeauté par lisa
azuelos et quand je disais que c'est un
film qui a accompagné les jeunes femmes
et les moins jeunes c'est vrai que c'est
comme une gourmandise on le regarde et
on leur passe encore mais c'est
tellement une gourmandise que pour être
tout à fait honnête les films que je
fais que ce soit les miens ou ce que je
fais pour les autres évidemment je les
vois pour la promotion que je suis voilà
mais après j'ai du mal à les regarder à
la télé parce que bon voilà je les ai
fais toi et celui ci ils passent en
boucle à la télé sur johan tschaenn et
je dois admettre que quand il passe ça
me fait un bien fou de le regarder à
chaque fois je me dis non je vais
regarder la première scène où cette
séquence là parce que je me souviens de
rien faire je regarde jusqu'au bout et
seul c'est le seul